protesters are back on the street in
Hong Kong they are now angry about a
proposed extradition law many people
feel this law could be used by the
Chinese government as a tool to
prosecute political opponents this
process however might not change
anything
so let's back up and see how it all
happened as a special administrative
region inside Chinese territory Hong
Kong has a different legal system and
has long enjoyed freedom of speech that
other parts of China don't have if the
law passes political opponents could be
sent to China and face unfair trials
come on a million white singing fool we
see come on oh yeah come on I'm going to
see my dying in which I'm today Malloy
also enjoy a local a pieman indeed i
which had indeed emotionally autism to
happen so why is the law being pushed to
a fault it's because of Hong Kong chief
executive Carrie Lam Lam might be the
leader of Hong Kong but she was not
democratically elected to even get on
the list of candidates she needed the
approval of the Chinese government
responding to the angry protesters lamb
denies the Chinese government's role in
the latest bill proposal this bill is
not about mingling alone this bill is
not initiated by the central People's
Government I have not received any
instruction or mending from Beijing to
do this bill however if Lam wants to
stay in power or even secure a second
term she needs the approval of Chinese
government and China has already
expressed eagerness to pass it jungchi's
agenda
hang on so you don't tweet in soothingly
the window for the bill to become law
still needs more than half of lawmakers
vote and it's probably going to pass
because currently the majority of them
have approached an a stance but they
still a slim chance for surprise outcome
in 2003 a controversial national
security laws packed demonstrations of
over 500,000 people this led to a pro
Beijing party withdrawing his support
forcing the government to shelve the
bill
this however only happened once now
protesters are hoping that history will
repeat itself